i'm a ready six
[Music]
[Music]
the mjolnir exosuit is now complete
[Music]
even though this technology will save
humanity in the war to come
[Music]
i must remind myself
liquid crystal cannot rise on its own
[Music]
titanium alloy cannot prevail in the
face of extinction
armor cannot help
it all means nothing
[Music]
until you step inside
[Music]
am i dead already i must be i mean this
is a punishment right
yep this is death
no no no
this isn't happening i'm going to have
to make an emergency landing
hold on
no no you
i can't stand it oh you are
freed no you don't get to tell me what
to do
you don't get to tell me anything we're
are you even listening i count three
anti-aircraft cannons
three what you'll be safe here
i'll be safe safe
i haven't been safe since i found you i
found you remember
you were out there on your own and you'd
still be out if it wasn't for me
i thought i was going home there won't
be a home if we don't stop the banished
you keep saying that we're outgoing
outnumbered
i know i saw condors over there i'm
going to dig through them and find one
with the working sleep space drive
and when you're done with this war we'll
get away from here
far away wait here
oh please
let me see what i can find canon's first
when i get back we can look
together
[Music]
okay be good
uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
i'm turning around
hmm
now
cool
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[ __ ]
hi hold on
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
so
your people are broken
scattered haunted defeated
by me i wish i could tell you it was
difficult
but it wasn't
we are one step ahead always
the ring is already under our control
soon the auditorium is well
share the same goal we fight
together to honor the will of atriox
without challenge i grew
weary lost
alone
here you now stand
this is my last fight
true test of legends
our story will outlive
us both
[Music]
set of fire in your heart spartan
bear your fans
fight hard i will
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed your first look at
halo infinite's campaign
i'm incredibly proud of the team at 343
and we're thrilled to share a hint
of the epic battles that await you on
the next chapter of master chief's
journey
this is the most ambitious campaign
we've ever created at 343.
for the first time players will have the
freedom to explore a mysterious new halo
ring
that's several times larger than our
last two halo games combined hill
infinite has been built from the ground
up to take full advantage of xbox series
x
bigger battles epic vistas more complex
visual effects
displayed with 10 times the processing
power per pixel
of halo 5. this will be running at a
flawless 60 frames per second and will
allow us to bring the halo ring to life
in ways that have never been possible
before
we look forward to sharing even more
about halo infinite in the coming months
including the first look at multiplayer
and now
please enjoy a glimpse of what others in
the xbox game studios family have been
working on
[Music]
world premiere
[Music]
ah
uh
[Music]
so
welcome everyone to the xbox game
showcase
today we're showing games from nine of
our 15
xbox game studios including unveils of
five new first party games what you will
see today
is how xbox game studios are harnessing
their passions
to bring their dreams to life
we believe that how you find and play
your games is as important as the device
you play them on
xbox game pass is the best way to
discover and play
and we want you to be able to experience
as many great games as possible
so game pass members you can play
every game you see today from your
subscription or free to play
these games will look and play best
on xbox series x delivering unmatched
fidelity
performance precision and immersion and
we've designed
the most consistently powerful next
generation console
and we've built state-of-the-art
platform technology to allow
every developer to realize their full
vision
one studio that has always pushed the
limits of our hardware
is turned 10 and they're early in
development
on the next forza motorsport and xbox
series x
is bringing them closer to their dream
of unprecedented
realism with ray tracing and native 4k
resolution
all at 60 frames per second
the trailer you're about to see was
captured
completely in engine
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our world has a rhythm
we all sense it
but only a few truly feel it
it is found in the smallest moments
in every step of a perilous journey
in the symmetry of ritual
[Music]
in the bonds we share
and in moments of stillness
[Music]
it teaches us to look beyond the
expected
to be a light in dark places
to seek answers
and to stand watch
our world has a rhythm
we all sense it
but only a few truly feel it
[Music]
everwild will give to you a magical
and untamed natural world for you to
explore
and to just truly lose yourself in it's
a place to be
eternal an eternal has the gift to
sense and feel how magic flows through
nature
and connects every living thing
the team here at rare are so excited to
be working on something like everwild
and i hope you're excited too but i just
want to take this opportunity to say a
massive
massive thank you to everyone who's
shown their support
and love and for the incredible awesome
positive community that's already
growing around this game
thank you thank you thank you
whoa i just got hit with a flood of
memories
love you mom you seeing what i'm seeing
mom allison
it doesn't matter that they don't
believe
us we all believe that what happened
that night was self-defense
but we couldn't be sure
it doesn't matter that they kept us
apart brother
sister we look out for each other it
doesn't matter that finding the truth
feels impossible
we're all done with fairy tales the only
thing that matters
[Music]
is you're my brother
and the only way to move forward
is to keep looking back
we've been getting these visions
whenever we see or hear something really
emotional
[Music]
everything we thought we knew about
marianne just got thrown out the window
loved you she attacked you we both saw
it
[Music]
i thought coming here would be closing a
chapter of our lives
nothing good comes from stirring up old
memories
we don't really have a choice about that
there's always a choice son
i can't do this
[Music]
hey everyone my name is gennady i'm the
co-founder and director of technology at
moon studios
today we are very excited to tell you
that we're working on a very very
special version of ori and the will of
the wisps
specifically for xbox series x we are
now at a time where we can reach
levels of fidelity and frame rates
previously absolutely impossible on any
console
an already gorgeous game like ori can
now run at 120 hertz refresh rate
in full 4k hdr in its highest quality
delivering unprecedented game feel with
silky smooth animation
super crisp sharp image and low input
latency which is just so
important for the tight and precise
platforming feel
of this game we can also boost the
immersion
in different spaces in our world by
using premium audio tech
that we previously just could not
simulate in real time
and with all of this crazy hardware
power we can give
our players more options with how they
want to play
our game we can't wait for all of you to
experience this very special version of
ori
coming to xbox series x with smart
delivery later this year
[Music]
from the furthest reaches of the
universe comes the biggest mystery in
the galaxy
an abandoned research facility and now
shady corporate intrigue
marvel by the gorgon asteroid
a sordid stopover full of salacious
secrets
and scandalous strangers greetings
attractive patron
you are looking down right on a bubble
today
with the right kind of case he wanted us
to develop a miracle drug
can put you on the wrong side of a gun
or sword or this
thing
thrills danger
intrigue a word of advice before you go
captain
trust no one
what will you find on gorgon
this unit cannot bring you any drinks in
its current state
if you're waiting
for the biggest game of the year
then wait for cyberpunk
but if you're ready for the smallest
we've got you covered
[Music]
from obsidian entertainment the makers
of games
that are nothing like this one
this summer strive together
to thrive together or just feed your
friend to the spiders
and go solo
so
at obsidian were dedicated to pushing
narrative and role-playing games it's
something we do
every day when we come to the office and
we can't wait for you to play our next
great adventure parallel on gorgon
it's the first of two planned story
expansion packs for the outer world that
we're putting together with our friends
from the private division now it's also
important that we continue to evolve how
we tell stories and games
and grounded is the perfect example of
that the team has been working for the
last two years
on how to tell an obsidian story within
a survival game
now what's great is that you're going to
be able to play the game on july 28th
on xbox game preview and on steam early
access we want to hear from you and we
want to continue to build grounded
together
oh yeah if you've been wondering we have
been working on that next big obsidian
rpg
check this out world premiere
we have always known war
it forged our empire
turned heroes into queens and kings
and decimated our foes
[Music]
now our oaths are lost
[Music]
forsaken
you must face the monsters
our sins have borne
[Music]
is an oath worth the weight of a crown
a vowed is an expansive first person rpg
set in the fantasy world of eora when
obsidian entertainment joined xbox game
studios they told us that this epic game
is the one they want to make as creators
of critically acclaimed rpgs
this is obsidian at their best and it is
being built from the ground up
to take full advantage of the power of
xbox series x
at xbox game studios we also work with
independent developers
always with the goal of empowering them
to bring their
ideas to life i'm excited to announce
our work with interior night
a new studio led by some of the most
talented storytellers in our industry
let's meet caroline marshall studio head
of interior night
to debut their original game
bonjour i'm caroline from interior
knight
our team is really passionate about
interactive storytelling
because when you play your story you
step into the characters shoes
you get to experience their fears their
hopes
their conflicts first hand and in the
process you learn more about yourself
and this is quite powerful our first
game
spans 30 years in the american southwest
it's a story about family resilience and
sacrifice
but most of all it's about how you will
shape the fate
of real flawed people trying to find
their way
in the world they don't fit in i hope
you enjoyed the trailer
world premiere
fortune fashion smile and fade i haven't
seen
much of
we were on our way to start a new life
that summer
for our family it was just a stopover
for mine it was the end of the road
on the ground now the sun went down on
all of us that day was it fate
coincidence no
that was a long forgotten secret
buried in the dark
all my life i've been scared of the
shadows
but now i'm finally ready to step into
the light
[Music]
i got your letters
here at ninja theory we're hard at work
on all of our projects
including senua saga hellblade 2 which
we announced at the game awards
back in december
an incredible 3.5 million players have
now experienced senua's story
in hellblade senua's sacrifice we're
excited to start giving you an insight
into what comes next for our celtic
warrior
an experience that we'll be building in
unreal engine 5
for xbox series x and pc
i'm happy to reveal today that senua
saga will be set in the beautiful
country
of iceland
and you can find out more about our
location scouting
and how we've discovered the history of
our setting and a brand new
behind the scenes development diary
which you can view straight after the
show
on the ninja theory youtube channel
it's been so touching to see the impact
that hellblade central sacrifice has had
on so many players
and we're incredibly thankful to all of
the fans that have been
part of senua's story so far we're
excited for you to be part of our
development journey
from here on out
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
do you want to say hi to peter he's on
the line what peter peter has been
sitting there the whole time
hey who wrote the song uh peter
oh peter fantastic work love the song
very much it's gonna be fun to sing it
now it's time to
to rock shall we start rocking
probably been a long time since you got
a visitor
i hope you don't mind poppins
[Music]
where are we it's a quiet place
lost alone
neither skin nor warm
just a thought is all i've got
now my covers blow
at the bottom of a lake
a frozen feeling
when my friends pulled me back up
i started
[Music]
[Applause]
healing
[Music]
through my cosmic eyes
[Music]
sensors are the magic keys
they kill the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
which are never
[Music]
never
we can't wait for you to experience the
amazing games built by
xbox games studios and there is just so
much more for you to play
on xbox we are partnering with thousands
of creators
from the largest publishers to the
smallest independent developers to bring
you the broadest variety of games
ever there is one developer in
particular that is close to us
not just geographically but in history
too
i'm thrilled to announce that this fall
our friends at bungie will bring destiny
2
to xbox series x and xbox
game pass if you are one of the more
than 10 million game pass subscribers
you also get access to all current
destiny 2 expansions
starting this september for game pass
ultimate members
destiny 2 will also be playable on
mobile
from the cloud later this year
bungie will also release a new version
of destiny 2
that is optimized for xbox series x 4k
resolution
running at 60 frames per second here's
an all-new look at bungie's destiny 2
beyond light
i've seen terrible things born out in
the darkness
every moment brings them closer
it's time to step beyond the light
[Music]
[Applause]
this is destiny 2 that you can play any
way you want thanks to xbox
game pass some of the world's most
inspired developers are working on games
for xbox series x and we're just honored
to be able to collaborate with them
xbox series x will empower both new and
experienced creators
to bring the future of games to life
like never before
unique perspectives unexpected
innovations
and fresh voices that demand to be heard
and that we can't wait for you to
discover
all of the games you are about to see
are being built to launch
exclusively on xbox consoles
thanks and enjoy
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
world premiere
[Music]
here
[Music]
um
my lord inquisitor i've reached a term
of prime
and begun our investigations
our recon squad has been sent into
sub-level six of the hive
to determine the full extent of the
unrest
i'll know more when they make it back
if they make it back
world premiere
when you were born something changed
my heart could not contain
the miracle of this world
and all that it creates
[Music]
[Music]
there is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow
world premiere
[Music]
approaching orbit scans a no-go sure you
want to drop here
so yeah
what we got another good-for-nothing
space rock
hold on let me check
[Music]
find anything good
you're not gonna believe this
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
it all starts with a dead girl
the forest the moon
scent of pines
and then
the gunshot
every story has two sides
a regular rational one
but also a darker and deeper truth
not unlike a nightmare
i can see both worse
i can lift them
hello anyone there
what is this place
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone everything world premiere
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
i've seen your future
global
[Music]
destiny chose me to save this world
and i will see it done
blacklist we make our own path we
protect our own
can you protect me from fate
17
[Music]
soon the entire world will burn
all because of him
[Applause]
today you saw 10 world premieres
and 22 console launch exclusives
game pass members can play every game
you have seen today
from xbox game studios and all of our
partners
in the subscription or free to play this
is just a peek
at some of the new titles coming to xbox
series x
and some of the games you already love
and some you have yet to play
will also be optimized for xbox series x
games like
forza horizon 4 gears 5 and sea of
thieves
you'll get the next gen upgrades at no
additional cost
when they launch you can expect a lineup
of over
100 titles for xbox series x
this holiday season with series x and
game pass
xbox is the place to play and you
are at the center of everything we do
now you may have noticed we didn't get
to visit all of our xbox game studios
today
that means we'll have more to share
later this year
but until then here's one more thing
world premiere
[Music]
the world is filled with stories
of legendary heroes
and treacherous villains
of fantastical creatures
and wondrous places
where nature and magic
live in perfect harmony
not all stories have happy endings
[Music]
but yours has yet to be written
[Music]
right here
[Music]
[Music]
swag
[Music]
[Music]
as well
[Music]
[Music]
you